what is going on there citizens of the recheck
Nation we are back for the Mandalorian season
three finale John how are you you excited I am
man Delirious with excitement Greg work play
Michael you excited yes oh yeah don't want to
try to compete don't even try to compete yeah
ladies and gentlemen yeah I got it I was late
you know what to do use the force to leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated also thank
you to everyone who has joined us on our patreon
page especially with the show we've got a bunch
of other stuff to offer over there as well I'm
excited we're all into this I got some new comfy
pants speaking of which we got a sponsor today
Greg roll that special sponsorship ad thank you
to me on these for sponsoring this video man I've
been wanting to work with them for a long time
now now obviously we here at the reject Nation
love to rock apparel that resembles the things we
love to talk about the most because the clothes
we rock off and feel like a reflection of our
identity not just who we are on the surface
but who we are underneath the surface see what I
did there so even though right now Gregory over
here is wearing a very soothing meandi shirt I'm
taking the next step forward with below the waist
clothing featuring Rocket Raccoon and Groot
from Guardians of the Galaxy of course this
collection is also limited edition so if you like
what you see you better hop on it before it's all
gone all right I'm gonna get real with you guys
I'm a married man my wife knows I don't mind
just walking around the house with my pants off
and I like to see your cute smile when she sees
me in these as much as I like the look of them
I always really care to be comfortable because
comfort in what I'm wearing just makes me feel
a lot more relaxed to be on camera and it's just
like that in real life so now I feel like my
identity and comfort package is now complete
I'm by no means a clothes expert but people will
attest I'm kind of picky when it comes to kind
of fabric I put against my body and this clothes
are just so soft even the shorts are so soft these
have been extremely comfortable for just regular
day-to-day activities lounging around the house
and even exercise you guys even know there's some
videos that you've already seen where I've been
wearing them the whole time because why would
you it'd be a little weird for me to announce
what underwear I was wearing at the time on
top of that too you guys who watch regularly
know I'm usually liking sweats or pajama pants and
undoubtedly these lounge pants here not only look
cool but my God these are now without question
the most comfortable soothing pants I have ever
worn on camera so miani's of course is undies
socks loungewear and a bunch more with sizing
ranging from extra small to 4XL yeah rejection
the hype is real they have a guarantee that if
you are not impressed with me undies your first
pair on the house that is a promise so to get 25
off your first order plus free standard shipping
go to meandies.com rejects once again that's
meandies.com rejects thank you again to me undies
seriously thank you for sponsoring this video
I never subscribed to the
whole there's a spy amongst
this Theory I thought that was just spies plural
up there use the capital ship
as a deep coin we can't beat
them in the air I'm entering up for
atmosphere but I have my order oh boy
I've
got a bad feeling about the fleet up there
hey you got a POV yeah
oh nicely done
oh wow
this is a flame retardant Cape
that punch strong punch there yes
yes
no I almost forgot my God
you're a negligent parents
help me up
Ellie
Gideon this will never end
kill moth Gideon we escape
to the surface I know what
we can hold up let's go this way I don't trust him
everyone's a spy everyone's
a spy they're all working
from off Gideon high interceptors are gorgeous
it's locked off shots have been amazing
their capital ship will soon be destroyed
but the Mandalorian has escaped
shall we engage no I'll take care of him myself
I'm very impressed at how they somehow made him
scarier whoever does the microphones in
this universe A Plus or five come in R5
R5 I'm counting on you good
luck we're all counting on you
Droid off mouse droids yeah it is extraordinary
how much character an Astromech has
good job buddy oh they're launching
fighters to destroy The Fleets both
the gauntlets and send all available
troops down as reinforcements screenshot
I'll take care of the cruiser
everyone go move okay ax wolves
this is so freaking cool
Wowie
come on R5
buddy
I mean let me let me in let me out
single-handedly do this never
underestimate acts freaking wolves
oh
armor is gonna save his ass
wowie I don't know hopefully
armor M.I.A there's some barrier Shields I'm gonna
need you to deactivate them one at a time on my
command yes sir Brooks I love this Phantom Menace
reference right here deactivate the first shield
oh my God it's like poetry it rhymes
oh dark Troopers suck you should pull one
into a corner and steal their armor yeah
honestly worked for Han and Luke next field this
is really cool it's a good steak oh come on buddy
these guys really suck it's like me with
sock and Boppers it's more fun than a
pillow fight oh next shoe I thought I was
equipping weapons like a video game exactly
thank you
that is our best car Shield
oh boy Mouse cop
this is an excellent physical
comedy from the Droid
there we go
yeah I'm working over here
Amanda Wick oh my God
what the hell are you gonna do it awesome
oh he is cloning himself to make
Troopers you want something done right
let's knock it in I thought
his pecks were bouncing I
know you gotta work them out don't open your eyes
CGI face there yeah let's go a
bunch of naked moth Guardians
and I hope they have to fight them all in the nude
where's that business or
we didn't have fresh drinking water in
yet here we had a beautiful underground
Oasis your reinforcements have arrived yeah
buddy okay I still got a bad feeling about
it there's no way she's a spy let's take back
our planet I do not subscribed to this Theory
haha
hell yeah look at her go I am flying I am the
armor I am aerodynamic found it hey my man
leave that cool shot lead them
so I'm so glad we get to live to see this
oh baby
badass shot
my ax
holy [__] it's like watching
bees dude this is pretty cool
she's a spy she's a bad one oh
wow holy [__] that was awesome
here he is redoing what he did at
the end of season two my clothes
we're finally going to be perfect
by adding the one thing I never had
that's what he's been trying
to do when Unstoppable Army
you smothered them before they could draw
their first breath um oh no fascinating
come on grogu you got Force Powers take him out
you just kill the dance man oh
foreign
[Music]
seriously do something Kroger
I really should have held onto that dark
saber oh bro goose thank you no no no no no no
oh my heart's racing right now
what the hell whoa what are you doing
they wouldn't Roku dude you're training
oh my God
okay well we can just force them push
away don't worry they'll get the door
open and they'll just be crumpled
in a big red ball oh great shot wow
I'm kicking ass
[Music] wow what a boss
no yes finally all right
there we go watch IG die twice
[Music]
do you know
God that can't feel good
it's like a robotic element to his armor
yeah well and like the hydraulic sounds
hell yeah
oh my God yes I've been saved by a
woman what the hell surrender or fight
did he build it oh okay I thought he built himself
a light that's pretty cool
though I'll give him that
boy okay
oh [Music] this is Kroger's
whole fighting okay yep oh
hey
wow let's grab it jeez thank you
there's a straight up like a video game oh my gosh
you're not gonna take my helmet off
hey bro
[Music]
dope the wickalorian yeah
Peggy I still owe you that dance
a little busy right now
whoa got him on the throat there almost [Music]
ring no that's all right there's a better
symbol than that to rule Mandalore oh yes
mandalorians are weak once they lose
their trinkets the Mythos are just
gonna show up out of nowhere
Mandalorian stronger together
crash the ship right into him right on
off Gideon's head no but actually though
wow there's some great aerial sequences here it's
terrific yeah that shot beautiful
effects work across the board wow
it's the fire and particle Sims like Jesus
oh thank you Kroger crush his helmet yes
sliding in
whoa
you mean his Armor's not fireproof he'll come
back with it melted to his skin or something oh
[Music]
buddy look at this happy family do it
it's a great shot I'm so glad they were
able to get the one ring to Mount Doom
[Music]
you have earned so many frogs little guy
ah they're gonna turn the
great forward John oh there
first words maybe he'll ride the Mandalore I
mean the Mythos are I mean another I'll come true
it's easy for season four at
least I need something he is
too young to speak so he is
too young to take the Creed
his parents are far from here if
they're even alive to say it then
then I will adopt him as my own
[Music]
Mandalorian Apprentice
take your Apprentice on his journeys just as
your teacher did for you this is the way oh cool
he sees it yeah wake it up
HMS Titanic [Music]
connected to the Mythic I'm
liking this foreshadowing
it's like kind of like Galaxy's Edge
wow
clap like normal people you've all got hands
[Music]
what is this hat you don't have the resources to
protect the outer rim let alone hunt down Imperial
remnants and I need work nice let me get this
straight you want to work for the new Republic
on a case-by-case basis it'll never get
approved which is why you won't tell them
let me think about it you already did scrap
assassin Droid head I need it for parts cabin
just outside of town they load with your new
family if you choose some between Adventures
you as well Gina Carano all right
she's back baby amazing citizens
I am at your disposal and served at your pleasure
everybody lives
I am din Skywalker [Laughter]
thank you all he needs is a guitar and we're
set I'm back to eating your little frogs
[Music]
what an interesting there were no spies
I didn't subscribe to any of these spies
theories no I thought they were all ridiculous
I think I think our little Astromech friend was
the other spot I don't know there was no other
spot there was very little place too much into
that I was like it's just a tally episode
guys definitely got some thoughts on this
finale definitely got some thoughts on
the show it was like a Marvel ending a
little bit a little bit I I like that they've set
themselves to go back to their Roots there is no
post-crediting no it's about to start no there's
the book of Boba Fett is gonna start Star Wars
they just wanted to suffer you have to respect
the Deutsche they always hated Star Wars
but no there it is it's loading in the words of
my best friend John oh campia he says don't turn
your speculation into expectation good that's
a bar and you know what I hope I hope people
abided by that when watching this episode because
I can imagine that Star Wars Theory right now is
yelling at his live stream while we are filming
this for sure there was an extraordinary amount
of payoff in this episode you think so no but
bro said it would be completely satisfying I
was I was satisfied in the sense that it was a
beautiful visual spectacle and while watching it
I loved every second of it and the minute that it
ended and I realized that I didn't get any of the
things that I was hoping I'd get I was left with
this fleeting reminder that I am a Star Wars fan
yeah and this is this is just like the life that
we live yeah guys listen I never subscribe I I
never subscribe to the whole there's a spy amongst
this Theory I thought that was just spies plural
plural correct it was just the episode it was
it's literally just the title of the episode
and it meant something there and then everyone
went read way too much into it but who was the
other spy will mean something much further oh my
God everyone Let It Go listen I'm I think they
do that why don't we screw up last couple years
okay I think in season two of tales of the Jedi
I think that we'll share some payoff to who
that spot maybe the Spy was Dave filoni in
the Cantina yeah no listen uh overall I still uh
I thought this episode was fine I thought it was
fun it was fun I think it's the the weakest
of the finales of all three seasons I I felt
um no Stakes uh weirdly no stakes and there was
like fun visual spectacle and yeah I think overall
to in my opinion and if you don't have this
opinion I am so happy for you my opinion this
is easily the weakest season out of all
three seasons of Mandalorian uh I cannot
uh I'm not I'm a little surprised because it
took a long time for the season to come out I
felt like they've had a decent amount of time
to plan it I don't really know why this one
is the one that seems to have the least type
of emotional impact for me maybe not for you
uh however I do think that this was just a a fun
predictable Road finale you like this or it's just
let's buy the numbers as it can get and I did
it there was like no surprises other than okay
they advance that he's called din grogu now Coupe
cool uh I grow goo to me is I was surprised by how
little he can do I mean he came in with the fire
thing but I'm like you you did that in the first
season this is just a little bit more a little bit
higher up there he didn't immediately fall asleep
afterwards he just sat down so that's progress
yeah there's a lack of there's seriously a lack
of stakes for me here and um we got some answers
about why moth was trying to get the Clones
cool even that just didn't do it for me like
yeah yeah like it was a mistake to destroy all
the clones and then fake us out with another
MAF Gideon death well or kill him again either
way yeah I think it's a bit of a waste of so many
cool like so many cool poor tents when you're in
there and you're like oh man this is his plan and
he's I don't know I guess these are the only ones
he had and he left this place completely abandoned
while he walked off to lure them you know to him I
don't know his yeah the maneuvering of this plan
on his end didn't make the most sense to me if
those are the most precious thing on this planet
but definitely like straight out of the like poor
evil villain Playbook of like oh I've captured
you but I'm gonna prolong your death and tell
you my evil master plan uh and then it gets out
uh yeah yeah I mean even Din breaking out was like
that to me was such a wonderful high-stakes
thing going in where it's like oh great I
protagonist is in a genuinely precarious situation
or it's hard to imagine him breaking out and that
just felt like hey yep immediately Sue season's
in and and uh the the the what were they in the
um in the in the second season the troopers death
Troopers yeah that's true the death Troopers oh
it's the same exact thing only this time they
didn't come out of their like robots yeah but
this one they're people in there yeah yeah they're
just it's it's a formula but the death Troopers in
the second season he had to fight one and that
was a struggle and then scary and the thought
of them all breaking through when when they
hit before he had to eject them all into space
yeah that was that was more intense just the
suspense of them about to break through yeah
anything with these Troopers is than both of these
episodes it is surprisingly underwhelming and yeah
they reclaim Mandalore uh cool cool I can't wait
to see Boca Town lose it again uh yeah just I'm
I'm I would have been totally content with us
being like cool look at all this work we put
into Navarro let's like spend some time build some
more susp answers it's just more I think about it
the more I don't like it I'm not gonna lie Yeah
the more I think about it the more I'm like whoa
I'm leaning towards this kind of sucked yeah it's
very jaggedly organized season that just the the
inside of the Walt Disney Company at the time of
development for this season was not in a great
place and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna write
it off I think and and I I say this with like
nothing but love and appreciation in my heart for
Star Wars we know they can do better they gave us
like so many little nuggets of it this season and
in previous Seasons I think they knocked it out of
the park Once Upon a Time this was your favorite
Star Wars show uh no I have none now now you're
a Mandalorian without a planet no I mean uh I
I thought the battle to reclaim Mandalore was
epic and fun and the calvary Collision of like the
mandalorians versus the Imperial Commandos and jet
packs was just like visually it looked really cool
it was really cool but it has to be more than that
um this felt the most cartoony this this season
felt other than a couple of episodes this felt
the most cartoony and I know some people really
like that because it makes them think of Clone
Wars went to me this show was not Clone Wars yeah
I love Clone Wars but it's its own this own thing
it's an animated show this is the the thing that
separated this was like the gritty westerns uh
Wi-Fi Bounty Hunter show and it doesn't need to
remain that uh but when you literally have like
oh yeah the ending feels like they're
trying to course correct back to that
in in a way and I I would be curious to
know because I'm sure that that like the
way everything went down with dinjar and grogu and
and the whole Boba Fett alley-oop of getting them
back together it feels like a machination from
the studio whereas like them retaking Mandalore
feels like a thing that that could very well suit
the show and yet it also feels like just because
of the way things wrap up like a thing they kind
of had to do or something like I felt nothing for
them no yeah absolutely no even like the four four
Mandalore I was like I should be crying right now
like as a Star Wars fan I've been waiting for
this moment for a long time and and it just it
was it was lacking the motion the focus was off
yeah as a whole it's not hard to see from the
beginning of like where you're headed at the top
of the Season you know that reclaiming Mandalore
will be a huge thing and a huge theme and as much
as I very like if you treated this more and I I
feel like it's a Trope to say this but more like
a Game of Thrones owns in the way that you really
realize the clashes of ideologies and the scope
and the space instead of going like season six
or seven style where it's like we're just sipping
around action and stuff they really bothered to
make those debates and those ideological clashes
tangible and focus that across all these episodes
because it does feel like there's like a chasm
in the Middle where like a bunch of other stuff
happens it's like episode three uh that could have
gone a lot better in a more you know nuanced game
of thronesy kind of season not to say that you
shouldn't have some of that fun I think that fun
is I enjoyed episode six a lot however yeah I feel
like if you really wanted to drive this Arc home
like this would be super meaningful and you can
still have DIN and grow Google out on adventures
afterwards but like yeah it feels like something
that got relegated to a few episodes and because
it got relegated to a few episodes it became
let's just do the action Parts yeah well I think
in one of the early episodes I made a strange
comparison to the same struggle that The Walking
Dead had from its early Seasons to when all of
a sudden it wanted to be a Game of Thrones it
wanted to be bigger but it didn't feel earned and
it was executed very poorly and by the time that
you got done with it they kind of killed the
best part of the show and you know I I think
and this is just absolute speculation from like
putting my producer cap on you know I think the
the master plan the The Cinematic story event
that they're working towards when they were
doing seasons one and two I I think they were
just focused on making a good story I think this
season put a lot of pressure to set those pieces
in motion but the story was very discombobulated
and you know I I know that they were supposed
to have Rangers of the new Republic which would
have helped supplement I I feel like they asked
this show to do a few too many things uh while
also just breaking an otherwise wonderful
formula that uh was a refreshing return to
why people like Star Wars in the first place yeah
there's a lack of an emotional core in this season
the biggest the biggest task feels somehow very
small yeah yeah there's no catharsis there by the
end I think it might have been more interesting if
there was a because first it was like oh we just
can't inhabit this place because it's like
dangerous to be here uh it would have been
more rewarding if if the obstacle was taking down
Imperial remnants that are occupying the territory
of Mandalore and that's the hardest obstacle they
have to overcome yeah that way there's an actual
sometimes now it just feels like they they got a
place yeah when they already had the whole thing
with Navarro because I know Mandalore means
it's Mandalore so of course it means something
uh but no they did there wasn't any true again
there wasn't any true type of emotional payoff
to it all but hey let's go through some other
[__] that happens in here just one quick note
the and this is a Game of Thrones spoiler when
the darksaber was crushed that reminded me of
that same empty fleeting feeling that I got
when the Iron Throne was melted like sure
like where I was like wow all this build
up and all this hype and we're just and I
was like over your shoulder maybe the mythosaur
like maybe there's something here that when and
yeah they just treated that moment like it
was just another sword gun but I guess they
can repair it inside I thought about the sword
guys it's about the person working together
who is part Mandalorian and part Jedi will build
and not part Knight two and part night of of of
Jack Black of Melissa that's right that's right
let it be known that is Canon and they will be
back ah God that well yeah we're all the Allies
we're I feel like we spent so much time building
a absurd cohort of characters uh on your left
moment yeah well that's like at least give us
like uh that that portals they didn't really do
anything with moth Gideon they really didn't he
it was it felt very tacked on yeah of he's back
again he's back again third time in a row we're
gonna we're gonna fight him just like we did
at the end feed him and he's got it he's got
a stronger armor now and and the fight with him
and bow that should have been very like there's
there was no tension there there really needed
to like slow down and simmer and this should
be a moment for Boca tan to fight again I said
it in two episodes ago like contextually there
was so much they could have played with here yeah
to just slow it down make this episode 50 minutes
instead of 40 uh and and that way you could have
some tension here so that way when they fight
like she lost to him this is her revenge this is
her this is her reclaiming right now uh and then
they don't give it's just like a fight season that
happens no that's exactly what it is and and it's
it's just really frustrating because you this
is a for for fans particularly of Bo like this
is a character build up that's been going on for
almost 10 plus years now um and to have that just
fall absolutely flat I mean I I keep thinking
back to like the bad badge season two finale
and they were able to create Stakes whereas
here there's a lot of characters that I love
there's a lot of things at stake but just none of
it landed no this this this this season most part
became just it went from like fine to lackluster
to a to a couple of things that I would love you
know I love like the second episode last
episode I loved yeah um I always were fine
you said something a few episodes ago Greg about
how dingrich didn't crack it correct uh yes uh
where grego my eggo sorry uh Everything feels fake
it feels very artificial I mean it it almost feels
like watching a fan film during some of these
episodes last sequence in in the Cantina with blue
is just like I don't know I just it felt so not
right now it's silly to say but like not real yeah
um which is such a Divergence from the first two
seasons oh yeah the cinema there's something about
the cinematography that is not like there's a
lot of cool visuals in this episode but there's
something about the cinematography with the
lighting that is not visually striking anymore
yeah and it doesn't it doesn't breed a certain
type of atmosphere anymore yeah I'll give them
the I think the the aerial combat stuff and
especially for how hard those effects can be did
look beautiful and I think definitely oftentimes
Rick family was the director who sells this world
the best to me um but I I would agree like yeah
this season is sort of permeated by an uncanny
valley of some sort and I don't know I mean for
for me the way that wrapped up with that whole
fight and him crashing the the you know ailing
ship into the ground and everything like that
sort of felt like it didn't really amount to
a heck of a lot other than engulfing them in
flaming and and with which effect was not a great
idea no I mean I guess that it's like all you can
do when you're just crashing and you're like
maybe I'll just use this to my advantage it's
a big planet you know but I hit that one hole
I think it would have been a stronger choice if
they just actually let moff Gideon get away like
instead of because it's either a fake out again
or he's just gonna be dead and either way it feels
yeah like a little stunted right when this season
he was seeming to peek into you know like no but
he's still scary he's still formidable commanding
and like even on the heels of this loss of all his
clones like where would that drive the character
so he was so is the implication that moff was the
first step to snoke like this plan no so that's
that's the the the Lost opportunity I mean in in
the previous episode where they talked about the
shadow Council and you had Hawks talking about
operation Necromancer that's snoke that's the
he just stole one cloner and then decided to
like make four sensitive versions of himself
which would have also just been cool to see
a bunch of like you know and they could have
all been like messed up looking and had like
pseudo Force I mean there's so many things you
could have done but instead we just got like
the most milk toast possible all it did was
get an answer to what was happening yeah and
even the answer was like kind of perplexing
how long does he think until they turn on him it's
my first red that is an illogical plan we've all
seen them no that's exactly what it is uh yeah
I mean I think there was a uh there was a golden
opportunity to let Gideon get away and I what I
had been holding on to as a fan is something I
think they've they've hyped up thrawn in words so
much but we've yet to see anything that makes him
an actually like scary formidable character
in my version he would have ridden off on
the mythosaur I would have just I mean that would
break your heart but that would be fascinating no
ah no I I it would have been nice to see thrawn
you know if if they're going to do an introduction
have him just like effortlessly wipe Gideon off
the map and at least then like oh okay we're
replacing this one big bad with a bigger blue
bad per Marvel um I don't I don't know I just I
this I'm not gonna lie this show this season
kind of ruined my love for these characters
I lost a lot of my love that I feel when
I watched the show buddy for the character
no it's it's super fair I mean I think
they've gotta they've got a nice setup
you know I think uh with with din jar and
and in grogu go and do admissions for the
new Republic it opens up to them going to the
unknown regions and you know playing a role
in in the Ahsoka story but I'm with you I'm
yeah this thought this this this is leaving
me a little dejected the more I think about it
the more it's the worse it just gets in my mind
reacting to the first two seasons and then
re-watching it on my own was like yeah I love
this show I love the first two I love the two
episodes that were only Mando focused and Boba
Fett more than most of the show this season yeah
it does feel like it came from a post Bobo yeah I
was even thinking if the mythosar showed up to
save the dab you're like like book above yeah
um but anyway as always next season Greg
uh so that sounds like they're course correcting
so that's that's the thing about Star Wars fans
we may be upset we may be angry we might tweet
our dismay and and said not so veiled threats to
Executives at the Walt Disney Company which you
should not do um but at the end of the day we keep
coming back because uh Star Wars is an abusive
relationship yes it is that's just the way it is
all right guys well what did you think did what
was your favorite part there was some beautiful
visuals I want to hear the optimistic upbeat
side of the Star Wars Community the reject Nation
Community is usually very optimistic they're so
happy I appreciate that uh do we think lizzo is
secretly a Jedi who escaped Order 66 yes is Jack
Black actually one of them off Gideon clones yes
yes find out next season on yes the Mandalorian
which I which hurts my soul to say I didn't it
was it was okay it was all right it was fine
it's fine all right guys May the force be
with you until the next one guys and thanks for
being here Michael oh thanks for having me Craig